اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
الاحتجاجات في فرنسا تدخل يومها السادس
السلطات تتحدث عن محاوله اغتيال استهدفت
رئيس بلديه ليل روز وتقرر نشره 45 الفا من
رجال الشرطه والدرك لحفظ الامن وزاره
الداخليه تقول ان مدينه مارسيليا ومنطقه
ليون هما الاكثر تضررا من اعمال العنف
الليله الماضيه الجيش السوداني يكثف قصفه
الجوي والمدفعي لمواقع الدعم السريع في
جنوب الشرقي الخرطوم وشرق النيل وانائب
رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه يقول للجزيره
ان محاولات وقف اطلاق النار تفشل بسبب
افتقارها لاليات التنفيذ الصحيحه حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي تقول انها اسقطت مسيره
اسرائيليه في اجواء مخيم جنين والجيش
الاسرائيلي يجري تحقيقا لمعرفه اسباب تحطم
المسيره التي قال انها كانت في مهمه امنيه
قيود جديده على مستخدمي تويتر مالك المنصه
ايلون ماسك يعلن تحديد عدد التغريدات التي
يمكن ان يصل اليها مستخدمو المنصه ويقول
ان القرار يتيح للناس ان يبتعدوا عن
هواتفهم ويذهبوا لرؤيه الاصدقاء والعائله
الى اللقاء